it's happening okay
so I'm sure a lot of people are aware of
that last night
there is like a marathon match between
nariditsky and Magnus Carlson
and going on right now big thanks to job
for tipping me on this match
um
Magnus Carlson is playing a match
against Ray Robson AKA spicy caterpillar
good friend of mine
I don't know how much these two have
played online before I know they've
played
I'll meet us like bullet on the chest
I'm not sure if they've played like an
extensive Blitz match on just.com
but I know Magnus is probably preparing
for the speed test championships coming
up
um it's probably why he's on these like
nighttime vendors
maybe early morning for him
wow Bishop H6
deflecting
are they playing with Rio but
everything's Rio happy Knights randomly
checked twitch into my delight the man
the myth and staff at Gambit and
stalemate trap Legend Eric Rosen started
a Magnus vs Rey watch party warm
greetings from Liverpool oh I should
update the stream title
that's a great stream Title by the way
Magnus vs Ray Robson
watch party
uh
okay stream title updated
warm greetings from St Louis
hope Liverpool is good as usual
oh Magnus is in in San Francisco
well it's still early morning for him or
no wait
no it's late evening for him
I forgot he's in the US
oh one optog got to meet Magnus today
oh so you have like actual real life
proof that he's in the US
wow
let me just fix one thing
yeah I met Magnus in St Louis a few
months ago
he travels a ton
he was in St Louis for a shorter time
than originally anticipated
foreign
first time chat from Zambia nice
hey it's Talia
what's up Talia
okay so I look away for a moment now
they're like kind of deep into an end
game
uh both sides have three Pawns
Ray's position looks solid but he has 24
seconds left
and maybe it's not so solid like Rook C7
may be coming
oh we're got five oh G4 nice prophylaxis
and Magnus is going to win on time
wow it's that was nine to one
okay so they've played 10 games so far
this is the first full game that at
least I'm witnessing the last couple
less than three thank you blundering
typhoons
so Ray playing a Catalan wow usually
it's Magnus playing a Catalan
yeah Reed's but been like diversifying
his opening repertoire
he used to be a
like staunch one E4 player
but now he's playing a lot of the
mainline Queen's Pawn openings
A5 I think is some weird sideline
and we have chest.com chat
someone's not impressed
I could play Guess the move
should I play Guess the move
I was doing some ghastly move after my
stream last night watching the the
narrated ski match
can I put on evalum
do people want Evo buddy
let me run a quick poll
evil bar question mark
yes no
one minute pull also I love you too
I eat Play-Doh
it's been so many years since I last ate
Plato
hey I guess I guess C6 correctly nice it
lights up green in the notation
wow
most people don't want the evalvar
I would probably vote no as well can we
see the poll here
and we'll see if yes can make a comeback
oh Andrew says I'll gift a sub for each
Robson win
I hope Robson wins the next like 1
million games
that could take a while though
Knight D5 it's a pork it's a pin plus a
fork
although okay Block's not winning any
material Bach was just getting rid of
White's Bishop hair
now yeah it's equal material a three on
two on the queen side
three on four on the the king side
it seems like raised time management is
much better this game
compared to previously is up about 20
seconds
and he still has this really nice
Caroline Bishop this bishop is a bit
restricted by
these super solid Pawns
and if trade trade
and White's controlling B7
I like the position I like the time
situation
but you never know like against Magnus
he's not gonna crack easily
and this is a nice neutralizing move
offering the trade of Bishops
and this should be roughly equal
but in a blitz situation
[Music]
I mean the 30 second Advantage can go a
long way
yeah the D file is the only open file
so I mean one idea is Rook T1
oh
okay so it's it's still a little bit
unbalanced
I wonder if they're gonna just repeat
and Magnus is not playing for a win
okay
I think that's the first draw of the
match unless let's see
maybe there were previous draws
no that's the first draw of the match
oh Ray had a match against nihal sarin
wow so now Magnus playing the Catalan
wait is Ray playing what Hans Neiman
played
what was ahan's Neiman line
oh and and Magnus was playing like he
played against Hans Neiman Knight C3
do they transpose
wait Magnus Neiman
uh I just want to find the chess game
not all the lawsuit articles
wait
how do I find the game chess game
there we go
I just want to compare
the line
oh it's a little bit different
because Hans took on C3 earlier
the ray still has this bishop on B4
oh sorry for the typo in the title
I had Ray Robson as one word
there we go okay title updated
oh we have the Explorer feature which
we'll show previous Theory
I was using this other day for the
Collegiate chess League commentary
omingus
oh no my Mingus
Mingus
mag
Ness
or mongoose
okay I think I fixed the spelling
okay
wow very very tense position black is up
upon
it has still all eight Pawns
this is very typical in McAllen or black
holds on to C4 but white has some nice
Central
uh control
[Music]
maybe looking to eventually play E4 or
G4 wow
I'm just just straight up going for the
attack
and recountering on the queen side
we should keep in mind Magnus Carlsen is
a reigning world chess champion
but Ray Robson
is a reigning world Puzzle Battle
champion
so Ray's really good when there's
tactics and puzzle-like positions
and position like this that's really
sharp
probably I I'd imagine he prefers it
more than like a dry positional game
although it can be a time drainer
and Magnus is still good at playing
quickly and very intuitively
wow
so yeah Black's defending C4 but really
has to be careful about the king side
ideally you'd like to just close things
down like H5 G6
the problem is is if if H5 immediately
then white can play G6 first
f69 F7
we might see this play out
it gets weird oh
okay so Ray
got some solid Pawns
Pawn takes what's idea
oh Knight G6 is coming
uh oh
B3
does that work
I think the queen like taking the queen
E4
wow Knight B4 so Ray's trying to remove
the queen from defending the knights so
if takes takes that would probably be
lights out for luck
but you're the queen that counter
attacks
so that was a funny line now this was
was attacked
a lot of things coming off the board
but the time situation
Magnus was in full control
GG
nice play by Magnus that game to build
up the king side attack
okay so now Magnus is playing a
greenfeld
no more Catalan
and this is an opening I don't know so
much about
can't wait to be born
hey
it's half year
hey it's me Eric
hey it's you Eric
welcome back good to see you
always nice to have some fellow Eric's
here
I assume this is still Theory
yeah over 100 games from this position
but rate taking some time so maybe not
in like full prep
oh tally is a Greenville player
Tally's Holly and chat says this looks
nice for VOC IDK
and you probably know better than most
of us
because at first glance it looks like
white has a really nice Center
but at the same time
like Queens are off the board the space
Advantage isn't too meaningful
and it's really nice Bishop kind of
piercing through the position
F5 while
a lot of central tension
Rook is really nicely placed along with
the King
this is nice wants to play King E2
Get Out The Way of the D file
yeah Knight B4 is also resource
I wonder maybe Knight before okay it's
played
there's something like Bishop b183
although whoa what's happening
whoa
I need a slow motion I need them to slow
down or I need a slow motion replay
a lot of things just came off the board
is very in trouble and takes Bishop F5
and then King F4 Bishop H6 Knight G5
Bishop H6 first
but now the King has a D4 Square
but where does a rook go because Rook
moves to the light square is
then Bishop F5 if Rook moves here Bishop
F5 King D4 Bishop G7
so Rook C4 Maybe
but it looks like a guaranteed shish
kebab
along one of the diagonals
oh Bishop E3 okay
it's another way to defend
King D4
I mean Ray already won King of the Hill
and is continuing to rub it in ha ha
King E5
is he trying to win racing Kings
no wants to move back uh oh
yeah Bishops are so good at like
controlling a lot of squares
because they don't overlap each other
it's the power of the bishop error you
just have maximum Square control
Magnus not even taking the Rook
maybe there's some compensation for
lights and Ray does have a pawn for the
exchange and has a pass d-pawn
the time lies down a minute
I wonder how much rating Magnus is
winning or getting for each each win
uh
yeah this looks
too Troublesome Rook C3
incoming
you are the chosen Rosen what is your
favorite planet
ooh
favorite planet
I mean I'm pretty fond of Earth
but if I had to choose a different one
what's that one with like all the Rings
Saturn
Saturn seems pretty nice
not something I've thought about too
much though
Italia says Rey was 30 80 when you
started watching
oh we can actually see like
3084 oh no wait he's losing how he lost
14 points
I wonder if he hasn't played Blitz in a
while and his rating is more volatile
I just want Ray to win a game
he won a while ago
wait what is this opening
we got distracted so it's King's Indian
I didn't know Ray plays King's Indian
black is down the exchange but never
mind I just won it back
material wise Magnus is up a pawn
but it's a spicy
it's a spicy position for spicy
caterpillar
foreign
trying to soften the king side a little
bit
okay now the rook's attacked
um rookie seven
Dole oh no my gusa move
oh Rook H5 I like that
yeah the combination of Pawn Knight
maybe Queen
okay G3
I mean what else to do I think you have
to play G3
but then the G Pawn's a bit weak H3
Queen E1
okay I got a couple crack moves there
it'd be fun to just play the uh like
predict the whole game
wait why not Queen take what is he
thinking about
oh another four
take
foreign
Exchange
is there anything to fight for you want
to hold on to the pawn like Bishop B5
it's not resignable just yet especially
like if the pawn can get to F4
then there's back ring potential
but if F5 then like Queen E5
oh it doesn't look good
maybe like D3
D3 Rook D7
it's hard to like just play for tricks
especially against Magnus for G7
adoption is usually when one player wins
10 in a row
I don't think it was time in a row
because of that half point
when did Rey win the first game
yeah I was in the middle it hasn't been
10 in a row
also Rey's like actually holding on here
amazingly enough
like Bishop D4 may be coming
combined with D2
okay so Rook F7 Rook F7 Queen E2
is Ray gonna win this
I honestly thought he was gonna like
resign
in a few moves
Queen G1
and Queenie two
still tricky
C1
and G2
Bishop H6
or take the pawn nice
oh The Bishop's coming to C1 wow Ray
really fought back but can he convert
with less than 20 seconds
because Magnus is not going to hold back
when it comes to dirty flagging
Queenie one coming
he should have enough time
but white might have like weird tricks
oh he's gonna put the bishop on E1
or not oh the bishop will just stay on
E3
and black can just start pre-moving
wow
oh he's triangulating so nice
but it's not so simple though
if we move take
nice
is coming back on time
don't stalemate though
oh there's okay good job with Bishop F4
oh if Ray's gonna win I think
keep moving keep moving don't stalemate
good
wow the clutch win let's go Ray
he was so down on time and down material
like he tricked Magnus
I think Magnus got a little bit too
comfortable
the game I should I should turn on my
heart rate monitor I feel like my heart
rate passed a hundred just watching that
game
GG
okay back back to 30 50.
who's trying to farm who
looks like Magnus is tilted a little bit
what was his opening Sicilian con
interesting that race which uh back to
E4
you play D4 a few times
uh Andrew with the challenge
yeah you got to be active in chat to
maybe receive a sub thank you Andrew
gifting to
a funny name
hey happy one year to Kung Fu chess.org
I gotta play some Kung Fu chess to
celebrate the anniversary
but only after this uh this match I have
no idea how long this this might take
foreign
I mean yesterday it was
I think I fell asleep before Magnus and
Donya finished
they played well over 50 games
interesting position
I mean at first glance I definitely
prefer white I mean really nice Stark
Square control they see four ideas now
um
it seemed like Magnus played some more
dubious line
of C4 not wasting any time
yeah because after it takes take so the
queen is attacked there's no time for B5
okay heart rate monitor is working
staying calm now
uh question can someone tell me if this
is tournament or just some playing
they're just playing
um
it's a cool age that we live in that
like the reigning world champion is just
having these
I don't want to say casual matches
but just these random matches online
against strong players
like it's a treat to watch because it's
such high level Blitz
do they just win The Exchange
wow
so White's up uh Rook for a night always
nice to see you good to see you too
archel G
happy 23 months
now I know Magnus has been grinding like
trying to raise his Blitz rating
maybe between games I can check if he's
number one on chess.com
there was a point in time he was like
neck and neck with Hikaru
oh Italia's 9 A.M Monday class got
canceled
it was meant to be okay don't get mated
as a maiden tooth Wrath
okay now Knight G3 there's Bishop G3
that's so sneaky the queen controlling
G1
Rook with X-ray vision
yeah time could be an issue but the
position looks good for white
this Knight's hanging
I just counter-tax an item B3
so Knights got traded
gotta be careful
Queen has
entered White's home
but looks like it's getting kicked out
uh oh
whoa wow if takes takes Rook H1 and then
Chuck and
was that even meeting
it looks scary to take though
black we went back material
King G1 was nice
nice option
oh no box Queen wait what
I don't understand what's going on
but lights up a full Rook now
but this Rook is pinned
and now it's a Time scramble again
Ray win two in a row
gotta start removing G5 no
Queen D3 nice consolidation and get
initiative Bishop G3
well he's just going for meat
but that's not meeting trade Queens take
the bishop
oof
move move
wow
let's go got the dirty flag what a game
Ray wins two in a row against Magnus
we were mentioning adoption earlier but
maybe it's Ray trying to attack Magnus
Domino's
okay I'm reaching a peak heart rate for
this stream that was intense Eric
getting a taste of what we feel when we
watch him play
oh this is um I think Ray played this
against San savian
US championships 2021
wait let me see if I can find the game
Robson 7 in 2021
see how good my memory is
okay
sometimes these openings will remind me
of
random games
or non-random games
so hopefully I'm not blocking anything
I just wanted to show the opening
it has the same line
are they repeating the same no
wait are they
they're repeating the same game what is
this
Sam Seville
that's so funny I remember like Rey
analyzing this game
is like he was almost winning this game
too
that's why he's so far up on time
because he's just just repeating a game
that he played
um about a year ago
so Magnus finally deviates from Savion
playing Knight F3 instead of Queen E4
and now Rey is probably on the zone
I do know raise games a bit better than
other players so that's it's easier for
me to
like recall openings he's played before
[Music]
foreign
I mean it looks like a lot of
compensation here
barreling down on both files I mean
queen G2 is a main threat
Rook G1
that's still Queen G3 and the oh F4
first
I don't fully understand
because black was trying to open files
okay the king is running
it's a bong Cloud Square
yeah I'm watching without engine I guess
some people want to watch with engine
evaluation
um
you can watch on chess.com
but uh we did do a poll more people
voted for no eval bar
and generally that's what I prefer
so pawn count is equal but the pawns are
very spread out
white found some King safety
Ray's still up about 30 seconds
yeah sometimes if I watch with the
engine then I just got lazy and I'm not
as invested like I'll just keep staring
at the bar going up and down
but watching uh just the moves
um like it's so interesting to see just
say the ideas
okay light squares are a little bit weak
like what to do with this Knight Rook G6
but then there's a taken 95
yeah it seems like Magnus has escaped
like the opening troubles
but now he's getting into time trouble
or G6 nice defend the Knight
D5
it looks shaky
a block holding on
wow E6
E6 preventing Rook B5
but these pawns are menacing
wow Quincy five
oh then Queen A6
Knight C5 which king is less safe
and King on C2 looks really unsafe
Queen A3
I mean this looks like a puzzle Rush
tactic but where's the meat
if he can force a queen trade it should
be winning
though it's a time it's 19 seconds to 19
seconds he wants to promote
wow this night is so well placed
blocking both Pawns
F2
it just takes up oh
I didn't even see this through this rink
uh oh
wow controlling d8
oh no Knight C5
whoa what just happened
move
that's a draw what an epic draw
oh man
that was so hard to keep track of
everything going on
did rage's Ray was like 20 or um not 20.
they're 30 50 a few games ago now he's
30 78.
lots of farming
man
okay they have a
a new opening so
the previous game Ray was white he won
In the Sicilian con so Magnus is playing
as something a little bit more solid
a Spanish
archangel
is Bishop C5 variation
man these last several like the finale
so the last softball games have been
absolutely Epic
and Ray's been doing well since I
started watching like I tuned in when it
was nine to one
and now it's four to twelve
so since I started watching raise like
um
he's one more than Madness right or no
they've uh how are you awake at this
time
I'm watching some epic chess games also
welcome back Kavita
yeah
I mean I have to adjust my sleep
schedule
to be awake when Magnus is active
and that might involve turning into a
very nocturnal creature
oh in between move
so there's three attackers against the
pawn
but the knights still attacked
now you just move D5 so
blunting the power of the bishop
now there's only one Defender but
because there's pressure between these
Bishops I think
yeah the e-pawn was safe there
at some point you'd imagine the Bishops
will be traded
maybe bishop D4 first
foreign
[Music]
I think out of both sides my highest
rating ever
has been leeches bullet
I I peaked just over 2 900.
but my Peak shot Stockholm Blitz rating
maybe just below 2800
Goods to show there's like
there's many next levels up
what is the structure
Ray's holding on to the center which is
very important
Ray's also up a pawn
oh but looks like he's losing E4 it
takes takes takes takes
but white shouldn't be worse White's
gonna have this outside passer
can be very valuable in the end game
I don't think I have a reading command
okay so a lot of things got traded
watch out for tactics
this might be a threat actually
sneaky with the back rank ideas
now can okay you can't quite go for Rook
be a queen 8 because then White's the
first one to get mated
maybe start pushing A5
wait you gotta move
26 seconds
oh okay so he played G3
just make the king safer and now he's
going for the throat
you'd imagine Magnus could
just fend off the attack but this isn't
the easiest thing to stop
hey Queens get traded
A5
oh that was very very sneaky
he essentially provoked A5 so he could
take and attack the d-pawn
wait this isn't so simple anymore take
and then this
ah the King was too close
it's still tricky though
I mean you imagine it's an easy dirty
fog for Magnus
where he's playing really quickly
final position is just to draw to
clinking bear mugs clinking bear mugs
oh cheers
whoa
gotta remove the
wow is he gonna
wow
Magnus tried to dirty flag the spicy
caterpillar and got punished
did people see that that happens so
quickly
he had like 10 seconds
and played
he had to have played like over 20 moves
in the final 10 seconds
and chess.com you you lose time even if
you pre-move
so it's extra impressive
Magnus could have like taken the queen
and just
um probably secured at least a draw
by Ray winning another game
closing in on 3100. oh no my spicy
caterpillar oh yes my spicy caterpillar
so now they're like every game's a
different opening too which is kind of
crazy
this is a different variation of ragozan
thank you will the thrill
oh no Andrew's credit card
yeah Andrew's Andrew is offering one
gifted sub for every Ray win
I raise one
board games or three games since I
started commentating
now they've had a couple draws
I mean overall uh Ray's had two draws
and four wins
and two queens at least in that previous
game
hey thank you Andrew gifting to Joe
I was very kind
wait let me see if I can find this um
chess.com leaderboard
chess.com is it reading
I found this site but it just shows
classical rating not just.com reading
I don't know where to find it
um
and they used to have like a leaderboard
ah I found it
oh so Magnus is the highest rated
oh wow
look at this Magnus is the highest rated
on chess.com
he's the only player above 3200
ray raise number 10 on jass.com
wait what
I just miss what happened
looks like Ray lost a game
for his loss in several games oh Magnus
was playing this A6 line
this is sometimes what I like to play as
black
but Magnus is gonna do it with um
yeah like there's lines where the bishop
goes to E6 Knight t7
here maybe the bishop F5
yeah Ray's like losing a lot of points
for losing that game but I guess he just
hasn't played in a while so the rating
is a lot more volatile
yeah I wonder what's gonna happen if if
Magnus
well Magnus get to 3300 or will he fall
below 3200 and then lose his top spot
kazakaru is 31.97
[Music]
so
Madness just needs to drop about 30
points
foreign
move Queen G6 painting the e-pawn
and now that I can take and now white
has isolated d-pawn
I don't think we're gonna see any
Sapphire gambits in this match
that'd be fun to see though
yeah the the way I can show the match
timeline is to go to like gray or
magnus's profile have a great stream
Eric less than three oh thank you Lele
appreciate that happy 10 months
shout out to Lele
yeah I think black is already for Choice
here
like very stable blockade
I think H4 was
it intending to launch some attack
earlier but
now maybe it's a weakness A4 delayed
crab
here we go
what tea are you drinking I'm drinking
chamomile tea
this is from my tea partner uproot tease
foreign we do have the T command if you
want to get the exact same G I'm
drinking
that's good that I'm not taking in
caffeine
um
chamomiles and herbal tea
and it's way too late for caffeine 1 20
a.m for me
pay it's Jules what's up jewels
yeah chamomile is fantastic
oh
that it's there's too much of a time
difference here
objectively it should be a draw maybe
we'll see some
trade
I mean Ray's gonna have to pull off
another miracle
and we saw him do it before can he do it
again
because what you just want to simplify
ideally trade Knights but it's hard to
force
and it can be hard to pre-move too
I wonder if we'll see a draw offer
oh the king's gonna run around
or not
it'd be hilarious if Magnus over pushes
and loses again
a situation like this
we could see 50 move rule
so F3 moved 36 Ray has to get to move
86. and keep the same structure
oh okay no more 50 move rule F4
ah maybe yeah you want to suck tonight
between 92
okay the repeated ones
oh it's so intense can Ray make it F4
okay take
it should be a draw
94 pre-move
yes wow
so clutch
so here's the draw
inching closer to 3100
it's so crazy how Rey can do that
like he was down well over a minute
and Magnus was going for a dirty flag
too
if I finish the T before the games while
I end the stream I was doing that uh a
few nights ago
I think if I finish the T and they're
still playing I'll just make more tea
I have about half a cup
this is my love young mug
love ya
referring to my love for tea
wait I look away for a moment and Magnus
just wins Connect Four has a raging
attack was this a ninja
[Music]
uh some kind of like zamish
casting greenside wow
this looks really terrifying for black
I mean ideally yeah black wants to play
D5 and win the A3 Pawn
and create some counter play
or maybe okay maybe the planet started
running with the King
the king would be much safer on a
compared to G7
it's actually a really nice idea
not Seven's Garden
but if you play King f8
it actually looks okay
I'm guessing the move
hey I guess correctly yeah because if
takes and there's Rook takes or queen
takes
I've said it's still going to be a
Target though
maybe G4 but G4 F5
G4 F5 E5
okay oh E5 first
wow look at this tension
uh oh look at this battery
and you gotta play some Rook move
and blocks holding on
I mean why has one Vocal Point but that
one focal point is defend enough times
and it's not clear what white like what
else white can attack but C5 okay
preparing Bishop C4
it's a nice resource
book H7
and two for two with gas to move
wow D6
D5
guessing Queen D6
three for three
it feels so good to guess correctly
I've been guessing easier moves though
so yeah the pawn now shuts in the bishop
C6 is an idea
dough
wow
where does the queen go Queen G6
no Queen G6 leaves a night hanging
over then this Knight's hanging oh wow
oh nice Havoc
oh no the queen wait it's still not over
though
or is it
yeah Queen
has a rook and Bishop for it
but it's kind of crumbling
I mean King King B3 I assume
oh there's some funny sequence
but nothing's really working
[Music]
be funny to play A5
threatening A4 checkmates
maybe take first
yeah the king is so slippery
someone doused it in oil
GG
and Magnus played well that game
and playing while a lot of games
but the way he kind of broke through
with attack was impressive
hey it's enberg welcome back it's a
special stream
we're witnessing a match between Ray
Robinson and Magnus Carlson
and this was a Karo Khan
Ray playing Mainline
I don't think I've seen this line before
and I take you for a night back to C3
it actually looks like a scandi now
with the queen on A5
so Bishop A3
is this winning material
look at this move
we've take Spock wins upon
meanwhile black just wants to take and
Destroy White's position
what a cool move
I think Queen C1 holds on like Knight D5
Bishop D2
oh Bishop D2 first
so what's the point Bishop takes B2
then maybe Knight B5
not only hitting the queen
but targeting the dark squares
yeah so Bishop A3 is kind of a bluff
hey it's Irene what's up Irena
I didn't got a lot of people here
tonight
got chess side here let's give a shout
out to chassan
Chessa giving the shout out to Irene
solid position for whites
bit more space I mean this structure is
very typical for like a scandi or
carocon
main idea for black is usually C5 or E5
more likely C5
in this case open up the bishop
ooh
very simple idea
but also very strong idea just transfer
the bishop to
better diagonal
maybe bishop D6
and 95
.
yeah when the knights on E5 then I think
C5 is
generally the plan to go for
H4 rate playing like Alpha zero
we saw him do this in a previous game
and then like things fizzled in the
center and a pawn was just sitting on
each four
but I like this because H5 prevents
Knight G6
and H5 H6 might really soften the king
side
oh wow so A6 was played because C5
Knight B5
but Magnus I don't know if he plundered
upon or willingly sacked upon
he lights up a clean Bond now
time is equal
about
A4 delayed crab
okay Magnus using this D5 Square
oh is our takes
I think Knight of seven would be met
with Bishop G3
seem close to working though
I have a feeling this is going to come
down to some crazy time scramble
oh
I have no idea if that was a plunger or
a sacrifice
but Knight F5 there is maybe G4
okay so it's back to being equal
material
do you even Rook lift bro
three attackers against E5
but it's risky Pawn to take because now
the knight's pinned
oh tactics
replayed that so quickly too
puzzled battle world champion showing
his skills
yeah this should be a pretty simple
conversion
both players have 30 seconds but Rey has
an extra Bishop
and
everything falling apart from Magnus
it's almost demating that
but is it
[Music]
okay nights are traded
this b-pawn
nice move
yeah The Rook comes back in time
the Magnus is still slippery
this is not trivial
you raise still down on time too
you want to start pre-moving ASAP
two it's so close but not quite
wow Ray's finally up on time
threatening made in one
checkmate
so clutch
what a game
that was nice game by Ray
like Magnus blundered with F6
like that F6 Queen G6 it happens so
quickly
3101
[Music]
Magnus falling down a little bit
so six and a half for Ray
I could go to his profile and see his
rating Peak
let's
oh this is Rey's highest ever Blitz
rating wow
yeah Ray's never been above 3100.
okay these games are so fun to watch
like so many sharp positions
we have another one of these ragozen
Style
how did
the
G5
oh so Magnus willingly took with f-pawn
it was more common to take with H Pawn
and just reinforce the center
but I guess he values open file
yeah I think that last game demonstrated
Rey's
ability to play really quickly when he
needs to
because he was down on time for most of
the scramble like Jewel too
oh uh chess is going on
yeah for everyone just joining uh Magnus
Carlson is playing Ray Robson spicy
caterpillar
they've played 21 games so far
Magnus of course has a lead
but I think Rey's been gaining rating
because there's uh
I mean there was like a 200 Point
differential
but now it's about a hundred Point
differential
that's too bad reason on in the speed
test championship
I mean based on these games I feel like
he would fit in
oh
does that work oh Queen G6
good move
oh Queen H7 even even stronger
oh that's so Savage
yeah there's no coming back
takes maybe you can play that but it
doesn't look good
okay he's gonna try
I mean black does have this like
mishmash of Queen side Pawns wants to
play B4 not immediately getting mated
but the king is still pretty weak
E4 good move
yeah forcing the bishop away
can game nice tactic from Magnus that
game
also thank you DD chess happy 21
okay here we're seeing a BOGO Indian
don't think we've seen this opening yet
oh okay H4 was setting up uh a Greek
gift
Bishop H7 Knight G5 so H6 is a common
way to prevent the tactics
foreign
usually when you play H4 you leave The
Rook on each one
but I guess the prospect of rookie one
has some Merit
this Pawn's been hanging for a little
bit
not the most appetizing Pawn to take
though
A5
yeah A5 uh can be useful in discouraging
B4
because there's cases where white takes
can plays B4
this Pond is still hanging
oh that pawn was hanging too
H5
it's my guess clamp down
Knight C5 is coming uh each five is not
a good move
white might already be in trouble here
actually 17 month baby
oh yes baby
oh Andrew just got some uproot tea nice
thank you ano
or oh no
appreciate the 17.
yeah these matches that Magnus has been
playing have not been too frequent
like I can't really recall the last time
Magnus was playing consistently on
chess.com
but I'm sure that like a lot of the the
players who are playing the speed Chess
Championship
are going to be training
maybe a lot of them will be trading
anonymously
but it's cool to see Magnus playing on
his like public account
curious if he has any like Anonymous
account that he plays on
okay
thank you
yeah the d-pawns look weak but they're
hard to win
yeah well he didn't want to take and fix
the structure of her lock
but Queens are still on the board white
still has some attacking potential
in G3 there's also Queen C1 here
man this Pawn is just surviving
it's actually really crazy the way
Magnus is playing this
like just taking pawns and not losing
Pawns
okay losing the bee Pawn
a Ray's gonna have to pull another
miracle
and we've seen before he's capable of it
E6
there's a funny idea Queen A1 rookie six
and then checkmate
that Queen D4 nice neutralizing move
okay the bishop is still exerting
pressure
I mean Magnus is up three Pawns
but Rey is okay trying to generate
something
there's funny idea Queen G6
he might already be threatening it
because takes and then takes King f8
Rook F3
Queen oh Queen g6ers Rook C1 oh that's
sad
so Queen B2 okay creating the battery
wow
[Music]
oh it doesn't work for whites
GG
that Madness let's play was fascinating
in that game
thank you modern penguin
happy 22.
hey they're playing um a qgd this is
what I like to play
usually it's black
hey everybody's playing the positional
line ah
this is why I played against Levy we had
a bunch of games in I played the block
sign
so Magnus is following uh
a really nice game
between Magnus and kramnik so he's
basically following his own game
yeah this idea I was studying this
recently
actually I Was preparing the San Abu
Dhabi
I feel like this is a risky line to play
against Magnus but
I think Rey has played this more
precisely than kramnik
somehow kramnik like lost afcon
some point
uh oh
I think Ray's also losing that thought
yeah King E6 is not going to hold on to
the pawn oh 94 though okay
yeah and then if f396 so black is
actually holding on
a king can plop itself on F6
but this type of um I don't know whether
to call it an end game or queenless
middle game I have not even been here in
three months oh welcome back
happy 26 months
it's a beast of Darkness
just maybe lurking in the shadows of
Darkness
what was I saying
yeah this line usually
is annoying for black
especially if you're playing someone
like Magnus who just lives loves to
grind down small advantages
like black is is solid but
just is a little bit worse because black
has a passive Bishop like has constant
pressure
Knight E3 may be coming
but at some point maybe we'll see rookie
eight
maybe some Rook trades maybe not
each we're going to come at some point
uh this match was not pre-scheduled I
don't think
I don't think Magnus pre-schedules his
uh
just late nights
of marathon matches on chess.com
the speed test Championship matches are
scheduled though
usually I have the time
at least a few days ahead of time
that time wise
B4 nice move
foreign
still looks fine for luck
oh that was nice
oh maybe it's not so fine
yeah if if King takes B4 there is some
mating that
foreign
Magnus doing Magnus things
it's a nasty Fork
the biggest threat was was the main
thread Brook takes B5
the Rooks were just icing on the cake
so we have a French this might be our
first French
it's so nice to see such a large variety
of openings
because in other matches
sometimes players just play the same
thing back to back to back
I just realized I've had this chest.com
chat open the whole time
is there a way to like close this
aha disable
yes
okay
I think I've shunned everyone
I mean this looks like a very pleasant
French for white
sometimes the nature of the French white
just got so pleasant position and the
black has to counter punch
oh thank you Andrew
gifting to elizada
wow
so that's a temporary Pawn sack but if
Pawn takes Pawn there's 93 White's
guaranteed to win something back
yeah I mean generally if white can
successfully get an F5 in the source
structure especially with the castle
King
it looks like a pleasant attack for
light Ray is also up on time which I
think in the majority of games he's been
very far down on time
that's why opening prep is like even
more important than Blitz
and not only like the specific
preparation but just your comfort level
with uh type of position that you get
whoa almost four years
love hates us
oh Bishop G5 that's a timely move
F6 cutting off
the distant relationship of the queen
and Bishop
and Ray Ray essentially sacked a pawn
with F6
but now has like very clear targets
not to mention the time situation is
getting better for rain
up now a minute on the clock
and this looks terrible for lock like
these nights are doing
really nothing
if F6 F5 you just take
and then whatever takes back there's
Queen G5
and H6 doesn't really help defend G5
I wonder if Magnus will just resign here
okay he tries that five always on
poisson
I'm one for one with guess the move
another Free Pawn
now do you want to trade Queens
the thing about Ray he's not gonna
really go for a dirty flag he's just
gonna try and win on the board
which I think is the right approach
holding on to F6
and this should be a pretty routine win
nice move Bishop G7
oh
so The Bishop's feeding cattle in
Black's territory Knight H6 look at this
peace coordination that's so pretty
although now the Knight is trapped
did Magnus trick Rey
the Block's not even threatening to take
the knights
so what's happening
Rook C3 and then Knight E4
or F for a while
wants to play Rook cf1
Knight G8
oh but then King G7 oh Knight F7 nice
move
16.9 seconds for Magnus
but two Central Knights and two Century
ponds for Magnus
and threatening a triple Fork
yeah 95 looks like the obvious move but
then King G5 and oh he sacks back
can now Rey's probably going for a dirty
flag
that's so crazy how Magnus just survived
that it looks so bad for him
how dirty is this gonna get
H3
ooh
looks Magnus Pole to draw
yeah Ray's going for it wait was made in
one missed
I think Mason one was missed
wow
okay ray wins a kind of dirty game
but it's the nature of Blitz
I mean he he played so well early on to
just build a massive time advantage
what a crazy game
now another new opening the Von
creatures opening E3
oh tally has to go
well thanks for being here
congrats again for your class getting
canceled
hope you enjoyed your stay
oh disable chat
do I have to disable chat every game
it doesn't remember
my preference
okay interesting setup
both players kind of staying within
their own territory
yeah I'm not sure if this actually
transposed into an opening I mean it
does have some English vibes
very often in English you you do feel
kind of the bishop and trading on
a trade C Pawn for d-pawn
oh thanks Andrew gifting to
oh to the person who said MC flacker
that was a first time chat from epsync
Bishop H3 while
a cool swear for the bishop
I like the peace coordination for white
like they're all applying pressure in
various directions
and now there's going to be a lot of
pressure against G7
like yeah Bishop Essex was already a
threat there
raised down
what 100 seconds
time wise this is kind of a disaster
Knight G5 wow so if Knight takes there's
Knight H6 winning the queen
we're about to see some funny sack
I feel like Queen H6 was also possible
there
but this uh
yeah this is just about over
tough game
but they're trading punches oh we have a
scandi
we had an opening earlier it was came
from a Cairo Khan
that kind of transposed into something
scandi-like
so here we'll see raise prep
against the scandi
I mean Bishop D2 I think at some point
like there's some line Bishop d295
yeah Magnus won that last one in very
convincing fashion
so not Bishop D2 but Bishop F4
mean very simple solid harmonious
development for white
but also for luck
like both players following opening
principles
it's kind of like they know how to play
chess
yeah we saw a game earlier like from
that same structure Ray played the
position really well
also is a queen just trapped and the
Queen's just trapped
Rook d8 was really bad because it took
away the d8 Square from the queen
if Queen here there's Knight A4 and then
whenever the queen goes to C7 Knight G6
hits the queen defends the bishop
attacks the rook and the bishop
wait what Knight F7
Ray with a puzzle tactics
if king or Rook take there's a knight A4
trapping the queen
it's a different way to do it
what a Savage move
I think Ray's about to win another game
I wonder why he chose Knight of seven
over Knight A4
maybe this is just more direct
Magnus seems to be fighting
oh it's not so simple oh maybe it is
simple just take
one for one and guess the move
thank you
yeah I was thinking 984 Queen C7 Knight
G6
but I guess this to this win more
material
I guess it did
because here it's Queen for two Bishops
other lion Ray would win The Exchange
but still takes work like two Bishops
can sometimes be annoying against the
queen
the Bishops do control a lot of squares
and Ray is down a bit of time
G for a while at some point yeah I was
gonna say that
sacking might actually be
a way to simplify
although now F2 uh oh
this actually looks hard for white to
play
because box doesn't have three attackers
okay are you just going fullham
on C4
or F1
E3 is no E3
doesn't quite work
it looks so scary though
man Magnus was so tricky
H5
those H5
everybody just ignores it 29 seconds
down about a minute
take
going for the passer
this is gonna get really spicy plenty of
choice for caffeination purposes
uh black tea
I can share
uh I'll share the tea I had earlier
or the tea I had maybe about seven or
eight hours ago
uh
as this one Makai black tea
you can use the T command
also what's Happening Here Queen H2
or he's not getting muted
oh but Rook C3
and now it's a drawish rook ending rook
in three verse rook in three but Rey has
seven seconds
I don't think Magnus is going to give
him a draw
yeah especially being up upon now
and it's hard to pre-move
yeah what to do
GG wow that just really fought back
I was Queen for two Bishops
spicy caterpillar says
does he realize that his child is public
I think Magnus messaged him something
and then he just responded in the public
chat
okay
he took a very quick water break
I'm disappointed that he didn't get tea
hey they're playing a scotch
I don't think we've seen a scotch yet
hey Magnus really mixing things up
Bishop G4
[Music]
one sec phone is buzzing
your in-game chat messages are sent as
public after the game has ended
ah I feel like
I've sent messages before after a game
that I didn't realize are public
foreign
yeah that's not so intuitive
but during the game I assume it's
private
it has to be private during the game
anyway
um
oh I just I just remembered some funny
feature
foreign
[Music]
CEO and he was talking about this Emoji
feature
which I didn't realize was an actual
thing
and he was saying like the developers
worked so hard on it
can I wave
let's wave
what happens
oh the wave is only temporary
ah
what happens if I put the target
how do I remove it now
I remove it
wait
I feel like I just stained the board
I don't know how to remove it
can I add more targets wait
no
Emoji
oh there we go
wow I can put so many targets
ah I want to remove them though
okay
so they have different behaviors
oh
that was satisfying
oh hey it's Zen mode
I'm just clicking random things and it's
changing the layouts
yeah the players I I assume can't see
that like while I was doing it's only
for
my view in observing the game oh if King
takes there's knight uh G5
oh this is getting interesting I think
it's just winning for white though
Pawn's gonna run
84 though
oh wow wow it's a race
but there's about three in the end
it really resigns
yeah I'm really not sure
why I would use certain symbols
oh there's there's Danny wrench
pog
hey it's akaru
I could just like litter the board with
with things
this could make for a nice thumbnail
let me just zoom in on the bomb
okay let's wait for a piece to move to
the bottom Square
it's getting kind of late for me
okay let me update my settings too
remember
um
in Toronto at the speed test
championships
Hikaru
I could see hakara's uh stream or a
screen like before the game started and
it was getting like so many challenges
from people because he didn't have
challenges turned off dope
okay something finally landed on E5
but yes sometimes when I
when I'm in the play chess server it's
uh
it's useful to turn off challenges
okay
it's another position where
I mean Ray is down about a minute
he does have the bishop here though but
he's also down the pond
takes takes
um
as white you want to like rearrange
I feel like Magnus is going to win this
one pretty smoothly
a knight C5
are you still fighting though actually
can remove the bishop
or there's a line where the vision moves
and then take and then take
the knights hanging
thank you again Andrew gifting to Tony
hey it's Tanya hey what's up Tanya
was Dania also watching this match
we have the Donya command
also have the shallow command
yeah I think I was mentioning this
before and I think I assume most people
know Dania was playing an epic Marathon
match against Magnus
about 24 hours ago
oh dying was speed running
oh everyone should subscribe to dania on
YouTube for the amazing speedrun content
um so if you're just joining Magnus is
added again
playing Grand Master Ray Robson
spicy caterpillar
it's been some wild games
there were previous moments of the
stream my heart rate
was almost a hundred
oh thank you Aussie CX gifting to dania
it looks like uh yeah it looks like
Magnus is going to take this one
F4
hi you play Queen D to meet F4 with
Bishop H4
yeah when the play is concentrated on
one area of the board then Knights are
generally better than Bishops light pair
is probably just better than Bishop hair
watch out for G2
okay oh no
wow you resigned before you flagged
I was impressive
oh what is this called This is a
checkover
this is um I have a friend Catherine and
I'm Silva
from Czech Republic this is one of her
favorite openings
I think she has some like instructional
videos on this line
it's uh yeah it's one of these like
anti-sicilians that
this case it leads to a Marathi bind
more of a positional line
who's the other guy yeah this is Ray
Robson
he is uh the puzzle battle world
champion
and one of the top rated Blitz players
on just.com
foreign
What's Happening Here
and black has a space deficit
but it doesn't look so now it looks kind
of done
that was ponzagoner
maybe there's counter play
against E4
Queen E7
ah F6 is
is gonna hang
so now Ray's gonna be fighting
I was gonna say be fighting a pawn down
but okay Magnus chooses not to win the
F6 Pawn
rather going for A7
yeah very used to stream on on Twitch it
hasn't streams in a while
but he did recently um I mean he's been
working on his chest he recently crossed
2700 feet
uh we can see
I'll just quickly show the live rating
list
um
yeah he's 2702 feet away so he's
actually at his Peak pre-day rating
37 in the world
he just peaked like a few games ago he
peached shots.com Blitz too
wow so it's still equal material
but white has way more active Rooks oh
but black has tricks
like this is actually kind of dangerous
looking for white
probably has to play F4 H4
oh Rook D5 also a move
man we've seen the situation so many
times
where Rey
has a holdable position
but it's so down on time
can he survive with 20
20 seconds left
I've worked defends both Pawns
and you still made ideas just resigns
what to do
question what's your tennis match score
against Rey
um he usually beats me he probably wins
like
70
percent maybe 80 of the sets that we
play
but like it's always close
I think the last set that we played
it went to a tiebreaker
trying to remember
it's usually like six four or seven five
or seven six
unfortunately the weather has been
pretty cold in St Louis so
tennis will have to wait
if you want to see a video of us playing
it's on YouTube
if you search my name in tennis you'll
probably find it
yeah there's there's a few tennis videos
on YouTube
mostly on my extra Channel and clips
channel oh there's one ping pong clip
against Gotham chess
yeah I'm a casual tennis player
if I had to put a chest rating on my
tennis maybe I'd be like 1600
but there's not really like ELO ratings
in tennis
ranking system works a bit differently
I'm not playing the winner here in in
the chess games I'm just watching
I'm also getting kind of tired so I
might
wrap things up soon
oh I'm doing laundry though oh it's a
great gift
does this work
I needed to turn on over the laundry
I think after this game all
turn it over the laundry
so Queen H2
and queen F4 though
it was my guess to move attempt so
Queenie one Queen F1
ah then Queen G3
died too slow to play it
or Cafe coming
yeah I think this is close to resignable
maybe King King doesn't work
Bishop A3
take
yeah
okay I was three out of three with yasa
move
okay I'll be right back I have to turn
over my laundry
um I'll just leave the game going
enjoy the match
and BRB
okay
yeah my chair was speaking for itself
there for a moment
I'm back
now it's my turn to speak for myself
I did 93 work
I'm too tired to analyze I think there
was takes and takes
in the end the the G7 Pawn would be
hanging
can you quack for yourself
I usually like to Outsource my Quacks
to rubber ducks
I don't have a rubber duck I have a
teddy bear
I don't know why I have a teddy bear
here's my teddy bear
it's just been sitting
nearby
I usually usually don't show it on
stream
yeah although mod did not like the word
quack
not sure why
I bought that teddy bear back like maybe
seven years ago
because I was about to hop on a bus it
was like a Mega Bus
from Chicago to St Louis
and I realized I didn't have a pillow
so I walked into a Walgreens
and they didn't sell any pillows
but they saw the teddy bear
so I've got the teddy bear and used it
as a pillow
it was actually kind of comfortable
why does black not take the pawn
which Pawn
oh the g-pawn
um
yeah I probably ripped T1
there there would have been compensation
for whites
there may have been like a eventual Rook
G1 ideas as well
inevitably I'm going to miss certain
moves
wow
this move I'm not missing happy 2 25 a.m
Merrick thanks for your Chill Vibes and
ruined sleep schedule oh my pleasure
welcome back to evanism
so Matthew's just sack the exchanged
Rey is up to exchange
down on time down about 30 seconds
A4
E6 is almost falling oh there's this
idea
this is going to get interesting but
Bishop H6
Rook T1 King A2
okay Rook D6 was a safe move
can Ray pull a miracle
okay simplifying
this looks painful to the fan though
oh
Bishop E1
three is so good with the pre-moves
oh nice move for the night
uh oh
GG
nice play by Magnus
so I forgave the time
do it do it do it stop forget it I have
six I got my hopes up for a moment there
I of course are going into a Mainline
Spanish
this is one of the anti-martial move
orders
so Magnus is regaining some reading
it's still very very comfortably number
one obliterated on chess.com
Hikaru is number two at 31.97
now there's been no staffords this uh
this match
as far as I know I mean I I started
watching the match about 10 games into
it
but I'm pretty sure there were no
staffords before
someone would have told me if there were
I'm not sure if Rey has ever played the
staffer that's a different question
maybe not
yeah I can't recall I mean Magnus has
played Stafford he played one in the
streets of Madrid
Fabiano played Stafford Hikaru played
Stafford against me
I've gotten a good chunk of the top
players in the world to play it
thank you the troll toll
appreciate the first time Prime sub
Ray was not over 3100 when they started
as far as I know
um because 3100 was was this peak rating
that he got maybe
maybe about 20 games into the match
there's no official Rosen Gambit
but today the Rosen Gambit is
when I sacrificed my sleep to watch
Magnus Carlson play Ray Robson
I think it's a fun Gadget
ooh spicy move
goodbye to archol G
thanks for being here
yeah there is a stalemate trap
I'll be so proud of Ray if he pulls off
a stalemate trap
he would be capable too
foreign
is also very capable
I played the Safford against
she actually fell into a trap like she
fell into one of the cool traps but she
still be me
I came back from a bad position
knife F5
I've never played tennis against Marcus
Armin
I played chess against Morgan
sort of takes takes both Bishops are
still hanging
oh nice counter attack oh Knight E3
counters having The Rook wow what a
sequence
but Magnus now has two minor pieces
or The Rook
on counts equal
yeah time lies Ray's not gonna survive
foreign
this is where I would like try and still
make trap but oh what to do
just gotta move on
English opening
we saw the vine creatures opening
earlier E3
but now let's uh what do we call this
reverse allopin
pretty sure Levy has studied these lines
pretty thoroughly
who is the top three goats
here I'll share some goats
if you're interested
uh
uh where's the goats
here's a goat
I was playing chess with a goat in
Iceland
I was trying to eat the pieces
it was also really cold out
but
yeah this was like the goat this was
like the goat of all time
I typed in go in my Google photos these
are the photos that came up
this is definitely not a goat
this is an alpaca
this is not an alpaca
but these are alpacas
or alpaca
alpacas
and then that's a dog
ah this so this this is um
right around the corner from the St
Louis chess club
I don't I wonder if this is still there
but so I don't know if this is someone's
apartment or office
but it just says magnus's goat
I love how Google photos like recognize
this as a code photo
yeah it looks like Magnus is Gort
bang this is goat
that's all the proof that we need
just some random window spitting the
truth
oh I have a picture of me feeding a goat
a non-magnos goat
what's going on in this game
Magnus up a pawn G5
like a g
I only G5 really did anything I have
five
oh he's going insane because he needs to
create counter play
would you feed Magnus if you had a
chance
I would feed him my safer Gambit and
feed him upon
try and get the compensation
wait a minute Bishop B3 almost wins a
queen but there's Queen E2
and Bishop D5 almost wins a bishop but
there's King Alpha One
I think we'll see Bishop D5
wait what about Bishop C4
where does the king move
Ray's calculating like all the
discoveries
maybe even Bishop A2 check
yeah this almost looks promising but
after King C1 white has everything
covered
and white would still be up upon oh Rook
C8 oh
[Music]
oh B5
wow
so White's up two pawns but the king's
in the center D4 is hanging
Ray has 22 seconds
Gary resigns the Ally was solid there
okay here's a photo of me
it's more like me attempting to feed the
goats
the goat wasn't really into being fed
but I tried my best
photo was taken I think in 2017.
there's a small farm in St Louis with
goats
but Magnus isn't better at least most
often
dad's Grant's Farm
and in the petting zoo you're given like
um like these baby bottles
to feed the baby goats
okay here's a better photo here's here's
a good that's actually like
into it
was probably the last time
I feather baby goat
I don't feed goats too often
oh there's this photo
was this photo
I fed a deer a carrot in Indonesia
should I share this photo
it looks so weird though
this is feeding a deer a carrot but
somehow the portrait mode like blurred
the stem of the carrot so it looks like
the care is just floating
foreign
[Music]
one of those deer-like animals
that was a well-timed photo
yeah here is the photo like right before
right after
I'm just holding I was basically holding
on to the stem and then using my other
hand to take the picture
hey thank you pure Delights The Raid if
you're just joining I'm sharing photos
but we're also watching Magnus Carlson
he's having a cool chess match against
Ray Robson
have you ever been chased by a goat
not that I remember but
if I was maybe I suppressed it
deep into my darkest memories
what you normally take photos with
normally my phone
sometimes I'll take photos with um
my nice camera
like this this camera is um one of my
main cameras it's a
Sony
I actually have a couple swungy cameras
the one I shoot with more often is uh
Sony A9
whoa Ray is up a piece wait how did that
happen
oh Magnus went crazy you just sacked the
something
the tactics didn't work out
so raise up a bishop
for three so it's actually kind of equal
it's Bishop for three Pawns
generally the piece is preferred over
the ponds
I mean time can
maybe tell the story here
don't don't get forked gotta take
okay let me try and win guess the move
oh
E3 doesn't work we take
foreign
wow someone has 18 guesses correct
I would probably have to start from the
beginning
thank you
what's gonna happen though is Ray gonna
survive
I'm not sure if he's playing for a
winner for a draw
just gotta play not to flag okay Magnus
is playing for a win
these pawns are scary
oh
oh Knight D4 coming
well played
is that it
that might be it
seven and a half to twenty seven and a
half
wait was that adoption
it's very really not winning game for so
long
I'm sorry I missed most of that game
sharing like goat and deer photos
oh no that what that was 10 in a row wow
GG
okay well big thanks to Joe for telling
me that this was happening
because I went live I had no idea this
match was taking place
so Magnus is
3266
anyway I'm gonna I think I'm gonna get
some sleep
I encourage most people watching if
you're watching from the US
it's probably bedtime
so
hello YouTube If I put this on YouTube
let me know if you watch the whole thing
yeah there are some really fun games
like earlier I had more energy but it
was still fun to watch